also lots of basketball this summer
we'll give you the full rundown in a
moment but first remember this
event here ice cube's big three
basketball tournament
after taking last year off they are
coming back to vegas with a
vengeance three on three basketball at
the orleans arena beginning next month
this tournament gets bigger all the time
cbs will be broadcasting the games once
again
earlier today ice cube himself talked
with our john langler
on good day las vegas this professional
three played at the highest level by
uh a lot of former nba greats
um it's just a game that that we all
grew up playing
but to see it elevated to this level is
uh
man a sight to see to see seven footers
playing three on three
you know if you look on this poster
behind me we got all the names who got
all the game
uh we're gonna be right there in las
vegas i hear he's a bit of a raiders fan
too
yes okay so here's the busy schedule for
the summer of hoops we're calling it
july 8th both men's and women's usa
basketball will be in town
working out playing games before they
head to japan for the olympics
the las vegas aces continue their
playoff run throughout the summer then
ice cubes big three on three begins a
month from now and then how about
august 8th is this enough for you the
nba summer league returns to unlv
so get set if you thought we had a break
between the knights and the raiders
without much going on well
it will be a fast break okay hitting the
hard courts of las vegas this summer